[Music]
the electric car ruled the road early in
the 20th century and then the technology
was surpassed by gas
today the concept is cruising towards a
comeback its resurgence fueled by
concerns about pollution from
gas-powered vehicles and by worries
about over-dependence on foreign oil
this sassy looking sports car is leading
the charge for change
just plug it into any electrical outlet
and after a few hours it has enough
juice for a drive through the
countryside or for quite a few jaunts
around town
with no tailpipe there are no direct
emissions and if the power generated by
the electrical plant is clean everyone
breathes a little easier
but with a price tag in the six figure
range this eco-friendly roadster is a
luxury product
production begins with the first half of
the gearbox
a worker bolts a brass fitting to the
center and then attaches plastic tubing
to it the tubing will deliver lubricant
to the transmission's bearings
he inserts those bearings into slots in
the gearbox and presses them into place
using a hydraulic tool
he drips thread locking compound into
screw holes and installs a device for
locking the transmission it's called the
parking pawl
he applies more adhesive to screws and
threads them through the pawl to the
gearbox
using a calibrated torque wrench he
tightens them to a precise setting the
transmission is single speed with four
gears which they install in the other
half of the gearbox
these are helical gears their teeth are
cut at an angle for gradual engagement
and smooth operation
they're now ready for the rotor and the
stator both are electric magnets and
together they'll be the electric motors
driving force
they insert the rotor into the stator
where their two electromagnetic fields
will interact to create torque
transforming electrical energy into
mechanical energy
they hoist the rotor and stator assembly
onto the gearbox and bolt them together
they attach cables for wiring the motor
to the power electronics module later
it's a crucial part that processes and
regulates the flow of battery power to
the motor
this completes the electric motor
drivetrain
they lower the drivetrain into the back
of the pre-assembled car body
they position the motor mounts over
slots in the steel subframe
and once in place they bolt the
drivetrain to the chassis
now under the car they pull back the
rear suspension temporarily to attach
the drive axle to the gearbox
the axle is equipped with a rubber
encased joint that allows a rear wheel
to react to bumps independently without
reverberation to the other
the battery is next seen here in a
display model of the powertrain
the metal pack contains more than 6800
lithium ion cells and delivers 215
kilowatts of power
enough juice to enable this electric car
to accelerate to 60 miles an hour in
under four seconds
machinery now lowers the car onto the
battery positioning it in the front of
the gearbox and just behind the car
seats
they jack up the battery for a precision
fit
they connect wiring for low voltage
systems like the lights and fans
and now the brains of the electric car
the power electronics module
they install it on top of the motor and
battery and wire it to both
with all the wires connected the module
is equipped to convert dc power from the
battery to the ac power
it will then supply that current to the
motor as the driver steps on the
accelerator
with the vacuum system they drain air
from the battery and pump in liquid
coolant
colon continuously flows through the
battery to maintain an even temperature
throughout
the body panels are made of durable
lightweight carbon fiber
and with the computer software updated
and the car now completely assembled
it's time for a test run
as this sports car accelerates there's
no throaty roar unlike a gas powered
engine the electric motor takes off
quietly and quickly
[Music]
[Music]
you